les catalans ont répondu à l'appel de la
grève générale de ralliement sur toutes
les lèvres la liberté
libérez les prisonniers politiques
scande la foule mobilisée à la suite de
la condamnation de neuf dirigeants
indépendantistes à de lourdes peines de
prison
c'est pas juste que pour juste avoir
essayé à deux fautes et quand tout le
monde avait envie de faire
ils mettent les gens qui ont fait tous à
13 en 11 ans à la prison c'est pas
normal
la liberté pour les prisonniers
politiques mais plus encore la liberté
pour la catalogne
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour la dignité de notre peuple
nous avons une tradition très
démocratique et nous voulons choisi la
possibilité de ceux des très indépendant
au delà du nombre c'est un peuple uni
soudé dans un mélange de colère et
d'espoir qui s'est rassemblée ce n'est
sans doute pas un hasard si un oeil rivé
sur les événements du jour en catalogne
l'ancien dirigeant indépendantiste car
les spots gimone s'est rendu aux
autorités belges dans la journée à la
suite d'un nouveau mandat d'arrestation
émis contre lui par l'espagne chine pour
les reportages kingston j'ai toujours
dit je dirais toujours parce que j'en ai
l'obligation éthique que je pose la
violence at il dit toujours je crois que
nous sommes dans un moment où la
modération et la pondération de la
réponse contribuer à apaiser la
situation a dit le président pedro
sanchez rétorquant critiques de
l'opposition espagnole qui réclame une
action ferme de l'état pour mettre fin
au chaos
une fois de plus la nuit fait place aux
barricades aux incendies et au saccage
les affrontements entre manifestants et
policiers se sont poursuivies jusqu'à
très tard dans la nuit une sorte de
corrida avec chaque passage des
véhicules blindés de la police
les manifestants voient rouge et monte à
la charge ont rien fait d'un radio
canada barcelone